In our previous documentary about the
chosen, we showed you a pretty startling
clip where Jonathan Roomie openly admits
to being a Knight's Templar. If you
haven't seen it yet, take a look. I'm
wearing a mantle and a cross with a
little crown on it. Um, a knight's
cross. Uh, 5 years ago, I was uh kned by
the order, the solemn
uh sovereign military order of the
temple of Jerusalem. I lost my mind
there for a second. Um, essentially the
Knights Templar, which is what that is.
If you don't know who the Knights
Templar is, look at the structure of
Freemasonry. The Knights Templar is
literally the top step. It is on par
with a 33rd degree Freemason. In fact,
you can't get any higher, well, at least
any higher than they tell us you can get
than a 33rd degree Freemason or a
Knights Templar. on his Instagram which
was dated in 2020. It says, "It was an
epic inaugural event and on behalf of my
fellow Templar brothers and sisters, we
are so grateful to have been a part of
it. The guy who is stamping Jesus in
everybody's mind is literally on par
with the 33rd degree Freemason." Now,
here's where things get even more
concerning. Jonathan Rooney isn't just
claiming to be a Knight's Templar. That
title alone puts him on the same level
as a 33rd degree Freemason as we
mentioned in the other documentary. But
it doesn't stop there. Look at how much
he's using skull imagery. You've seen
it, right? Like the rings he's wearing.
He's wearing the clothing. He's got all
of the symbols. So what does that all
mean? Let listen to this clip from
Jonathan Rooney where he explains it
himself.
comes from a very deeply felt Catholic
Christian tradition
about mortality
and the need to recognize our mortality
and to cultivate a deeper sense of
holiness in our lives today because
tomorrow is not guaranteed. That's in a
nutshell what this is. Mmentoto mori
remember you will die. We will all die.
It's just a part of life. On the surface
level, this seems like a very honorable
thing to do, right? Like we should
remember that we're going to die someday
and we should remember to live our lives
to the glory of God every day because
someday might be our last day. But in
this momento mory tradition, Jonathan
Room is not alone. There's other
Catholics like Father Mike Schmidtz, um,
Sister Terresa Alata Noble, Bishop
Robert Baron, and others that all
promote this thing of momentomory. So,
let's talk about Bishop Robert Baron.
His Jesuit ties run deep. In this
biography that um Matthew Leing writes
about him, he highlights Baron's
admiration for Jesuit priest Pike Tower
the Chardin and Koner whom Baron says to
have been hugely influenced by his
ministry word and fire is also filled
with a ton of content promoting Ignatius
of Lyola and Ignatian spirituality.
Ignatius of Lyola being the founder of
the Jesuits. But momentum isn't just
Catholic. The Freemasons also claim it.
Listen to this from the Oriental Lodge
number 33 on their website. One of the
themes that Freemasonry emphasizes is
momento mori, which means remember that
you will die. Isn't that the same thing
that Jonathan Roomie said? So, let's
pause and connect the dots here.
Catholics and Jesuits teach momento my
Freemasons claim momento my is theirs.
And Jonathan Roomie, a Catholic actor
who admits to being a Knights Templar,
is pushing it too. So why do the
Jesuits, Freemasons, and Knights
Templars all promote the same concept?
Let's go straight to the writings of
Albert Pike, a 33rd degree Freemason
and sovereign Grand Commander of the
Scottish rights southern jurisdiction. I
have right here in front of me this book
morals and dogma of freemasonry.
Basically this is their religion. This
is where they say this is what they
believe. Now in chapter 17 Pike writes
the Templars or poor fellow soldiery of
the holy house of the temple intended to
be rebuilt took as their models in the
Bible the warrior masons of Zorobil who
worked holding the sword in one hand and
the trowel in the other. Therefore, it
was that the sword and the trowel were
the insignia of the Templars who
subsequently concealed themselves under
the name of brethren masons. The name
Frey Mason in the French was corrupted
in English into Freemasons. So, Pike
isn't just making an off-hand remark
here. He's drawing a direct connection
between the Knights Templars and the
origins of Freemasonry.
And in chapter 30, he takes it even
further, revealing what happened just
before Jacques de Mole, the last
grandmaster of the Templars, was
executed. The Templars were gravely
accused of spitting upon Christ and
denying God at their receptions of gross
obscenities, conversations with female
devils, and the worship of a monstrous
idol. The end of the drama is wellknown
and how Jacqu detoai and his fellows
perished in the flames. But before his
execution, the chief of the doomed order
organized and instituted what afterward
came to be called the occult. Hermetic
or Scottish masonry. In the gloom of his
prison, the grandmaster created four
metropolitan lodges at Naples for the
east, at Edinburg for the west, at
Stockholm for the north, and at Paris
for the south. The initials of his name,
JBM, found in the same order in the
first three degrees, are but one of the
many internal and cogent proofs that
such was the origin of modern
Freemasonry.
I've also got a Masonic Bible here. When
you open it up, there is a diagram in it
with the plan of the order of
Freemasonry.
Right here in the structure of
Freemasonry, you can see the Knights
Templar and their symbol. Now, history
tells us that the Pope Clement V
officially dissolved the Knights
Templars of 1312.
But the question is, did they truly
vanish or did they simply rebrand,
morphing into Freemasonry just as Pike,
one of Freemasonry's highest
authorities, admits? The order
disappeared at once. Its estates and
wealth were confiscated, and it seemed
to have ceased to exist. Nevertheless,
it lived under other names and governed
by unknown chiefs, revealing itself only
to those who, in passing through a
series of degrees, had proven themselves
worthy to be entrusted with the
dangerous secret. So, Albert Pike, a
33rd degree Freemason, admits that the
Templars eventually became the
Freemasons. But who really controls the
Freemasons?
In the book Freemasons magazine and
Masonic mirror volume 4, this is from
the 1800s a Masonic publication it says
on page 39 and9 the brothers and fellows
of the freemasons are the scholastic and
kodu spiritual as of the Jesuits for the
temporal or secular Jesuits are not yet
members of the order. They are not to do
their own proper will. For the order of
the Jesuits requires absolute obedience,
and the secular Jesuits do not yet know
that Freemasonry is under the direction
of the order. The secrets and secrecy of
the masons allude to the secrets of the
Nostri or not. The valley of Jehoshaphat
even by its initial J represents the
Jesuits and symbolizes the whole surface
of the globe where the Masons are not to
know that they are the slaves of the
Jesuits. By the way, they certainly do
not know it. The word mosaic, relating
to pavement, we are told, is written in
italics to symbolize the artifice of
Moses who knew how to blind the people
of Israel to make them his partisans.
The blazing star is the sun, the emblem
of the order, the symbol of omnipotence.
The master mason represents the chief of
the notress or nostri and refers to the
general the four principles the four
vows of the initiated Jesuits. So what
this masonic publication is saying is
that the masons fall directly under the
Jesuits but that only on the absolute
highest levels the masons are aware of
this. Now in his famous total onslaught
series Dr. Walter Vite shows some
pictures of him visiting a shrine. Pay
attention to the similar symbology
between the Masons and the Templars.
Now, let's go a little bit into some of
the history. I'm taking you to this
beautiful palace. Where do you think it
is?
It's in Jerusalem
and it's Natradan Vatican.
And this is where the Pope has his
representation in Jerusalem. It's a
palace for a king. There's the Vatican
flag flying outside. And here is the
Knight's Palace, the Latin Patriarch.
This is where the Knights Templars
originally had a site. If you go inside,
there's this interesting altar. And as
you look at the altar, you'll see
certain figures over here. This one over
here is very interesting. Let me get a
little bit closer. And what do you see?
You see the double-headed eagle which is
also the symbol that is used in
Freemasonry.
So there it is on the altar of the
knights and what is there on this side?
Two swords helped like a compass.
Fascinating. So there are many many
Masonic fig figures in here. the tail
feathers and the feathers of the eagle.
Very reminiscent of what you have for
example on the back of the dollar and
all those other interesting symbols of
the circle with the triangle and the sun
around it and uh the inheritor of the
temper
nuance are the Jesuits. Now the Jesuits
of course
are the ones who behind the scenes
control many things. Even Helena
Blavatsky, a highly influential oultist
and worshipper of Satan, connects the
Jesuits to the Knights Templars.
So, Blavzatsky said that the modern
versions of the Templars were actually
inspired and influenced by the Jesuits
to try to Christianize what the Templars
actually believe. And of course,
especially those flavors that are
connected with Freemasonry. It's not
just us making these connections. Let's
take a look again at Walter V's total
onslaught series as he shows you how the
Knights Templars, Jesuits, and
Freemasons are all basically the same
thing. Christianity and the secret
societies, we could summarize it as
follows. The old Babylonian religion
gave rise to cabalism.
via the scenes and others nasticism came
into existence andnosticism
was founded by Simon makers this comes
from no other source than history lamagi
and uh byas Levi wow that's a high
masonic source so nasticism founded by
Simon Magus then thisnosticism
with its secret doctrine
was eventually over time through any
intermediary organizations
carried over to the Knights Templars.
And the Knights Templars were a group of
a Roman Catholic order if you like that
were set over the temple site to protect
it. And they had strong links to Islamic
societies, the Ismiles, the Karmatites,
the Fatimites, the Duisers, and the
Assassins. Now the Templars they had
their secret inner information
inculcated in the Rosacrruian and the
Jesuits.
The Jesuits again formed and created
Freemasonry. And Freemasonry was created
as the Protestant arm of the Roman
Catholic Church. Unbeknown to them,
beguiled, fooled, if you like, into
doing the work that Rome wanted them to
do so that Rome could sit in the
background while Freemasonry did it for
them. And then it wasn't them, it was
them. And it was mainly Protestants that
were doing it. and not Rome. Very
clever. Very, very clever indeed. So,
you can see how all this falls together.
How Jonathan Roomie says he's a Knight's
Templar, but then he also is really
flirting with the Freemason stuff. Um,
and then the Jesuits are like, well,
this stuff that the Freemason says is
theirs. It's like actually ours. But
really, if you look at the evidence,
it's all the same thing. It's all
intertwined and connected. The Knights
Templars even have the exact same cross
in their emblem as the Freemasons. And
they both have a crown and a sword. And
in fact, the Freemasons and Jesuits and
Knights Templars all have the same
references to the sun in their emblems.
Is that just coincidence? Let's let's
add another level to this layer. In an
interview, Jonathan Roomie reveals that
his father attended a Jesuit school.
My father's from the Middle East, the
family is Greek Orthodox and my mother's
Roman Catholic from Ireland.
And when we left New York City, we we
moved to the suburbs. There weren't a
whole lot of Orthodox churches. And my
dad, being a Christian in Egypt, went to
Catholic school run by French Jesuits.
Now, does attending a Jesuit school
automatically mean that you're a devout
Jesuit and somehow you're part of a
secret society? No. But when it comes to
Jonathan Rooney though, we've already
seen some strong connections between him
and the Knights Templars and 33rd degree
Freemasons and Jesuits. A but as we
continue, the evidence just keeps
stacking up. Recently, Jonathan Rooney
was kned into yet another Catholic
order, the Knights of Columbus. Now, on
their official website, they state just
a few months before sharing his powerful
prolife message on the National Mall in
Washington DC, Roomie became a member of
the Knights of Columbus. So, they they
even visited him on the set of the
chosen where himself confirms that he is
uh a member of this knighthood. T take a
look at this clip.
I always wanted to be a Knight of
Columbus. They're awesome fellas. I'm
praying for them constantly and the
mission and the people that they serve.
My reaction as a knight is to be present
with them. That's kind of how I feel
like I can give back to the Knights.
When you look at the official emblem of
this order, you will see the fascis
symbol. According to Britannica, the
word fascism comes from the Latin
fascis, which denotes a bundle of wooden
rods that typically included a
protruding ax blade. In ancient Rome,
lers, attendants to the metrates, would
hold the fascis as a symbol of the penal
power of the magistrate. So this is how
Britannica describes fascism. To unify a
country, fascist movements propagated
extreme nationalism that often went
handinhand with militarism and racial
purity. The prosperity of a nation
depended on a unified polity that put
the group's welfare above the
individuals. A strong vigilant military
was considered necessary to defend these
group interests. Now think about
Christian history. During the dark ages,
the Roman Catholic Church acted pretty
much the exact same way. Protestants,
people who dare to, you know, follow
their own conscience and they challenged
what they believe were unbiblical
teachings, they were hunted down. They
were tortured. They were killed by the
millions. And the goal of this this
persecution was to bring everybody under
the unity of Rome. Again, absolute
control with the pope at its head. no
room to have your own understanding of
scripture or your own conscience between
you and your god, your own beliefs
according to what you believe scripture
says is true. It even used military
orders like the knights of Malta, the
Knights of the Knights Templars and the
Jesuits to enforce this kind of control.
If you look at Pope Pas the 9th, he once
said, "The absurd and erroneous
doctrines in defense of liberty of
conscience are a most pestilential
error, a pest to be most dreaded in a
state." That doesn't sound like freedom
of religion. That sounds like fascism.
For today, Rome considers the fascist
regime the nearest to its dogmas and
interest. We have not merely the
reverend Jesuit Father Cochland praising
Mussolini's Italy as a Christian
democracy but civil tea to Catholica
which is an official mouthpiece of the
Jesuits says fascism is the regime that
corresponds most closely to the concept
of the church of Rome. So let me ask you
this question. Is it really coincidence
that the Knights of Columbus use a
fascist symbol if this is in fact part
of the church's history? And if this is
in fact according to the Jesuits this
closely aligned to the Catholic Church's
beliefs and Jonathan Roomie became a
lifetime knight of Columbus. If you like
this video, like, subscribe, and hit the
notification bell so you know when we
launch new videos and drop a comment
below and we'll try to get back to you
if we can. What?
Say that again. Oh, no. I don't know
what to say.